let's see if we can find the limit as
theta approaches 0 of 1 minus cosine
theta over 2 sine squared theta and like
always pause the video and see if you
could work through this
alright well our first temptation is to
say well this is going to be the same
thing as the limit of 1 minus cosine
theta as X approaches or not X as theta
approaches zero theta as theta
approaches zero over the limit as theta
approaches zero of 2 sine squared theta
now both of these expressions which
could be used to define a function that
they would be continuous if you graph
them they'd be continuous at theta
equals 0 so the limit is going to be the
same thing as just evaluating them at
theta equals 0 so this is going to be
equal to 1 minus cosine of 0 over 2 sine
squared of 0 now cosine of 0 is 1 and
then 1 minus 1 is 0 and sine of 0 is 0
and you square it you still got 0 and
you're multiplied times - you still got
0 so you got 0 over 0 so once again we
have that indeterminate form and once
again this indeterminate form when you
have 0 over 0 doesn't mean to give up it
doesn't mean that the limit doesn't
exist
it just means well maybe there's some
other approaches here to work on if
you've got some nonzero number divided
by 0 then you say okay that limit
doesn't exist and you'd say well you
just say it doesn't exist but let's see
what we can do to maybe to maybe think
about this expression in a different way
so if we said so let's just say that
this let me do some other colors here
let's say that this right over here is f
of X so f of X is equal to 1 minus
cosine theta over 2 sine squared theta
and let's see if we can rewrite it in
some way that at least the limit as
theta approaches 0 isn't going that
we're not going to get the same 0 over 0
well we can we got some trig functions
here so maybe we can use some of our
trig identities to simplify this and the
one that jumps out at me is that we have
the
sine squared of theta and we know from
the Pythagorean Pythagorean identity in
trigonometry comes straight out of the
unit circle definition of sine cosine we
know that we know that sine squared
theta plus cosine squared theta is equal
to 1 or we know that sine squared theta
is 1 minus cosine squared theta one
minus cosine squared theta so we could
rewrite this this is equal to 1 minus
cosine theta over 2 times 1 minus cosine
squared theta now this is a 1 minus
cosine theta this is a 1 minus cosine
squared theta so it's not completely
obviously out of how you can simplify it
until you realize that this could be
viewed as a difference of squares if you
view this as if you view this as a
squared minus B squared we know that
this can be factored as a plus B times a
minus B so I could rewrite this this is
equal to 1 minus cosine theta over 2
times I could write this as 1 plus
cosine theta times 1 minus cosine theta
1 plus cosine theta times 1 minus 1
minus cosine theta and now this is
interesting I have a 1 minus cosine
theta in the numerator and I have a 1
minus cosine theta in the denominator
now we might be tempted to say well
let's just let's just cross that out
with that and we would get we would
simplify it and get f of X is equal to 1
over and we could distribute this 2 now
we could say 2 plus 2 cosine theta we
could say well they aren't D is the same
thing and we would be almost right
because f of X this one right over here
this this is defined this this right
over here is defined when theta is equal
to 0 well this one is not defined when
theta is equal to 0 when theta is equal
to 0 you have a zero in the denominator
and so what we need to do in order for
this f of X or in order to
for this to be the same thing we have to
say theta cannot be equal to zero but
now let's think about the limit again
essentially what we want to do is we
want to find the limit as theta
approaches zero of f of X and we can't
just do direct substitution into if we
really take this seriously because we're
going to like oh well if I try to put
zero here it says theta cannot be equal
to zero f of X is not defined at zero
this expression is defined at zero but
this tells me well I really shouldn't
apply zero to this function but we know
that if we can find another function
that is defined that is the exact same
thing as f of X except at zero and it is
continuous at zero and so we could say G
of X is equal to one over two plus two
cosine theta well then we know this
limit is going to be the exact same
thing as the limit of G of X as theta
approaches zero once again these two
functions are identical except f of X is
not defined at theta equals the zero
while G of X is but the limits as theta
approaches zero are going to be the same
and we've seen that in previous videos
and I know what a lot of you thinking
how this seems like a very you know why
don't I just you know do this algebra
here cross these things out and there's
a substitute 0 for theta well you could
do that and you would get the answer but
you need to be clear or it's important
to be mathematically clear of what you
are doing if you do that if you if you
just cross these two out and all of a
sudden your expression becomes defined
at 0 you are you are now dealing with a
different expression or a different
function definition so to be clear if
you want to say this is the function
you're finding the limit of you have to
put this constraint in to make sure it
has the exact same domain but lucky for
us we can say if we found another
another function that's continuous at
that point that doesn't have that gap
there that doesn't have that point
discontinuity out the limits are going
to be equivalent so the limit is theta
approaches 0 of G of X well that's just
going to be since it's continuous at 0
we could say that's just going to be we
can just substitute that's going to be
equal to G
of zero which is equal to one over two
plus cosine to one over two plus two
times cosine of zero cosine of zero is
one so it's just 1 over 2 plus two which
is equal to you a little bit of a
drumroll here which is equal to 1/4 and
we are done